♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE HAVE MAJOR UPDATES
ON THE CARAVAN TONIGHT.
EVERYTHING WE BEEN WARNING YOU
ABOUT IS BEING PROVEN TRUE.
EVERYTHING THEY MEDIA PEOPLE
LIKE BARACK OBAMA, IT IS FALSE.
THAT IS A SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
MINI ♪ ♪
STILL CAMPED OUT IN TIJUANA,
MEXICO, FOLLOWING CLASHES WITH
U.S. BORDER PATROL OFFICERS.
RELEASING MORE INFORMATION ON
WHAT AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS FOR MANY PEOPLE.
WOMEN WHO WERE ASSAULTED DURING
THIS JOURNEY.
GRIFF JENKINS REPORTED THAT SOME
MIGRANTS ARE ACTUALLY
SELF-SUPPORTING AS THEY FACE
DIMINISHING PROSPECTS OF
ENTERING THE U.S. LEGALLY.
HE IS ALSO UNCOVERING THAT IS
BOTH THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS
BEEN TELLING US, THE VAST
MAJORITY IN THE CARAVAN HAPPENED
TO BE MEN.
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE TELLING
THAT ONE-THIRD OF THE PEOPLE
TRAVELING IN THE CARAVAN ARE
BEING TREATED FOR VARIOUS HEALTH
ISSUES INCLUDING LICE, SKIN
INFECTIONS, THREE CONFIRMED
CASES OF TUBERCULOSIS, FOR CASES
OF CHICKEN POX.
BY THE WAY, I THINK WE SHOULD A
HUMANITARIAN BASIS HELP.
LET ME BE CLEAR, I SAY MANY
TIMES, WHAT MANY PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SEARCHING FOR A BETTER
LIFE.
STORMING THE BORDER, ATTACKING
AGENTS.
THAT IS NOT ASYLUM.
WHEN DO ASYLUM-SEEKERS ACT LIKE
THAT?
WHO IN TONIGHT AND OF THE
MIGRANTS WILL FACE IN    IN THE
PROSECUTION DESPITE THE
PRESIDENT'S BOW THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE TOLERATED.
MEANWHILE, THE THREAT OF MORE
VIOLENCE AS PROPERTY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO SEND
DEA AGENTS AND U.S. MARSHALS
SERVICE PERSONNEL TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
JUST LESSON WE LEARNED THAT IT
ADMITTED MS-13 GANG MEMBER WAS
RECENTLY ARRESTED AT THE BORDER
CROSSING EAST OF TIJUANA.
HE IS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A
29-YEAR-OLD HONDURAN.
HE TELLS AUTHORITIES HE WAS PART
OF THE CARAVAN DESPITE MOUNTING
EVIDENCE THE MEDIA IS CONTINUING
TO DOWNPLAY THAT THE REAL
THREATS ARE THEY ARE IGNORING
THE FAILURES OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHAT THEY DID.
THEY SHOT PEPPER SPRAY AND TEAR
GAS AT PEOPLE THAT TRY TO COME
INTO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
NOBODY REPORTED ON IT DOWN.
TURNING US NOW, DAN BONGINO,
GERALDO RIVERA.
GERALDO, YOU GOT ME SO MAD ONE
NIGHTS.
HE SAID TO YOU, I TOLD YOU THIS
WAS COMING.
WHAT YOU TO DO SEAN?
YOU WANT TO SHOOT?
I'VE ACKNOWLEDGED TO YOU HOW
MANY TIMES COME UP THAT I WANT A
BETTER LIFE FOR THEM.
I SYMPATHIZE.
I REALLY DO.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THEM.
I WANT HUMANITARIAN HEALTH CARE.
WE CAN HELP THEM.
WE NEED TO DO IT.
THE PROBLEM IS, LOSS,
SOVEREIGNTY, BORDERS.
THAT IS WHAT MATTERS IN THE
IDENTIFIED CRIMINALS THAT HAVE
INFILTRATED THE CARAVAN.
>> HELLO DAN AND SHAWN.
I STAND SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
WITH BOTH OF YOU WHEN IT COMES
TO EXPOSING THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
ILLUSION.
I THINK THE HARSH TREATMENT OF
THOSE MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER
WITH THE PEPPER SPRAY AND ALL
THE REST OF IT, THE REST OF IT
IN OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Sean: LIKE OBAMA.
>> THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT RIGHT.
>> Sean: HOW TO DO IT?
>> OF THE 42 ARRESTED, EIGHT FOR
WOMEN WITH CHILDREN.
THOSE SCENES ARE ETCHED IN OUR
NATIONAL PSYCHE NOW.
THE SEPARATION OF THE CHILDREN.
>> Sean: WILL REVIEW THE OBAMA
YEARS?
>> IF INDEED THESE HANDS WERE
COMMITTED DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THESE ARE RIGHT.
WE HAVE A RECOLLECTION
WE CAN TREAT THESE PEOPLE LIKE
THEY ARE MS-13 MEMBERS.
IT WAS ONE MEMBER AMONG 7,000.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT HER BORDER
PATROL GUYS?
ROCKS, BOTTLES?
TEAR GAS IS GOING TO KILL YOU
AND I THINK PARENTS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PULL THEIR
KIDS AWAY FROM THAT SITUATION.
THAT IS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
>> GERALDO, I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS.
I CONSIDER YOU A FRIEND.
YOU ARE WAY OFF BASE ON THIS.
I HAVE STOOD AT ROLL CALLS, I
WAS AN OFFICER.
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR A PAT ON THE
BACK, IT WAS A GREAT JOB.
I ASK YOU THE SAME QUESTION.
GIVEN A LOT OF PLATITUDES.
NOBODY WANTS TO SEE ANYONE
TEARGAS.
YOU WIN, WE BOTH ARE EMPATHETIC
TO THAT.
THAT WAS NOT THE CHOICE OF THE
BORDER PATROL OFFICIALS.
THE CHOICE WAS MADE BY PEOPLE
WHO STORMED THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
I ASK YOU A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION
AND I WOULD SINCERELY APPRECIATE
AN HONEST ANSWER.
YOU'RE STANDING IN THE FACE OF
THESE BORDER PATROL AGENTS,
PATROLLING HER BORDER, JUST
DOING OUR JOB.
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING THEM TO DO
WHEN A ROCK COMES AT THEIR FACE?
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER?
NOBODY PRODUCES AN ANSWER?
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU DO NOT DO.
DO NOT SHOOT TEARGAS AT WOMEN
WITH SMALL CHILDREN.
>> Sean: YOU CAN ANSWER.
>> YOU ARE THE GRANDSONS OF
IMMIGRANTS.
IRISH IMMIGRANTS, ITALIAN, THEY
WERE SLANDERED LIKE YOU ARE
SLANDERING THESE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE DISEASE.
THE IRISH WERE BRINGING DISEASE.
THE ITALIAN SPRING DISEASES.
THIS IS A SLANDER.
WHAT YOU DON'T DO IS YOU DON'T
DO THAT.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> YOU SEND SPANISH-SPEAKING
AMBASSADORS TO THE CROWD.
HE EXPLAINED TO THEM THAT THEY
ARE NOT CAN BE ABLE TO RUSH THE
BORDER.
WE EXPLAINED TO THEM THE FACTS.
THE REALITY OF WHAT IS HAPPENIN
HAPPENING.
THIS IS THE STAND ON THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: THERE ARE HUNDREDS
CHARGED IN THE BORDER AND
CHARGING AT POLICE.
WHAT IF IT IS THOUSANDS?
WHAT TO DO THAT ON?
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT QUESTION
YOU NEED TO ANSWER.
>> WE BELIEVE THOSE WORDS ARE
YOUR LYING EYES PLEASE SEE THE
COMPOSITION OF THIS?
THE THREE SCENES OF THE ROCK
BEING THROWN.
WHAT ABOUT THE SCENES OF THEM
LIVING IN SQUALOR IN THE
ATHLETIC FIELDS.
THEY ARE BEGGING FOR FOOD AND
OVERFLOWING TOILETS.
THOSE INHUMANE CONDITIONS.
>> Sean: WHY THROW A ROCK?
>> YOU ARE SUGGESTING --
>> YOU DO WITH HUMANITY AND
COMPASSION.
>> Sean: LET ME JUST SAY THIS,
IF WE HAD THE WALL.